hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the live event to mark the end of
chapter 2 season 2 is so close it's
Saturday
to get you ready I've compiled every
single map change and story beat the
season has thrown up to get you in the
know no story theories here only facts
so slap code atom arrow in the star to
support this madness and think about
subscribing to and let's go through 15
weeks in one video
Oh quick question where are you going to
stand for the event I was thinking of
the agency but now I'm thinking risky
real so I can see everything it's a
tough choice what are your plans week
one can you remember the start of the
season way back in February 2020 we saw
the ego and otter squads become the
ghosts and shadow units due to the theme
of undercover agents and that tagline
top secret the agency was erected on the
central island led by the to100 skin
Midas his mini bosses were also given
brand new locations around the map meow
souls could be found at the yacht Brutus
was given the grotto TN Tina a
demolitions expert set up home at the
oil rig yeah that's that's not gonna end
well and sky could be found at the
sharkslayer
on top of that ai-controlled outposts
could be found all over the island
including the house in the middle of the
lake which was finished on day one of
this season also notes that Graham the
gnomes radio shack got a facelift
another henchman hot spot Graham stayed
safe so don't worry too much about our
Lord and Savior another renovation to
the house above Holly hedges had a
similar change to make it into an
outpost on the first day of the season
the chair truck which could be found the
docks finally moved little did we know
how important this moment was at the
same point a log jam palette truck began
to travel in the opposite direction ten
weeks later things got real we'll get to
that very soon surprisingly a box
factory appeared near the redacted
bunker it was confusing but once again
it would end up being very important
over in retail Row two offices sprung up
one for ghost 2 one for shadow vying for
our attention
and health taking down the opposition as
well as things that were added some
things were taken away remember all the
ego outposts from season one well
they're all gone they're all demolished
done and dusted does they say one of the
strangest map updates saw a police chase
end in a wreck
just outside sweaty sands you can see a
speed trap complete with donuts by the
cops oh and there's a cabin in the wood
now it just suddenly appeared we didn't
have to wait long for this story to
begin behind the bookcase was a secret
door to an underground lair the real
villain of chapter 2 was spotted our
community dubbed him Nick furry get it
in the basement the Bears were plotting
to take over Graham the gnomes empire
imprisoning Graham's twin brother no
less and yes the community named him -
Gandalf
keemstar Jerome the G no I really need
to stop letting you guys name things
Who am I kidding I love that rubbish
let's do more of that crap week two is
here oh no nothing happened fortnight's
moved to a fortnight update schedule fo
RT ni gh t see you next week week number
three the chair truck continued to move
this week now turning into retail ro and
the pallet truck has reached the
outskirts of misty Meadows here's an
update I bet you all forgot the addition
of heli pads the first one popped up up
at Grahams and another in the mountains
- and more in the works judging by these
wind socks found around the island oh
the massive monumental change occurred
over at Tony Stark's the iron man moved
his head slightly yeah it's a tiny
change kind of tiny changes another one
happened over at Ferris Bueller's house
as his once fallen Ferrari has now been
lifted by a crane but those footings
don't look trustworthy to me this week
was also the first time the community
decided on the allegiance of one of my
diseased cronies Brutus
found down at the grotto turned to the
shadow team his location has changed to
suit with this awesome skull design
like a bond bad guy how cool is it that
we choose how things adapt and change
in-game I bloody love it also I should
note that all around the map files and
suitcases and post boxes and posters
could be found all relating to
challenges bog ghost and shadow missions
but the big one that made me gasp was
that the agency the meeting room in
which Midas sits upon his golden chair
was missing who could have done such a
thing
well a canoe was spotted stealing the
golden throne and escaping across the
lake to a hidden getaway vehicle more on
that very soon week 5 has arrived the
chopper was added this week I have a
shiny pink chopper to impress the ladies
heli pads all over the map were
completed and the hidden chopper spots
underneath the football pitch at
pleasant park was revealed pretty damn
cool week 5 saw the change to the rig
something went very wrong the
demolitions expert somehow blew up the
entire oil rig who would have seen that
coming eh this place was now a shadow
location and luckily the room with the
old fought night memorabilia has
survived happy days
TNT now though is now officially a
shadow agent but what have you done Tina
look at this oil spill back to the
golden chair stolen from the agency this
week the chair has been stowed away on
the getaway vehicle and the culprit is
currently racing through salty springs
and speaking of chairs a quick update on
the chair and pallet trucks they are a
little bit closer this week and the
crane at Ferris Bueller's house well
yeah it fell off into a heap and back
then I said this I hope we see another
bigger crane built to pull this crane
out let's see how that prediction pans
out more tiny updates this week as the
iron man has begun to hike around the
island an awesome touch to note is that
he has a walking stick where could he be
going oh and this was the week we got
loadouts in fortnight only 16 months
after they were said to be coming
[Music]
week seven is here down by the agency
five missile silo looking objects could
be found in the water the hatch is
remained closed but we could see some
sort of purple juices from Kevin the
cube were found inside we all knew this
was important so we'll have to wait
until the end of season event inside the
agency remember Midas's lost chair well
look now he's got a substandard desk
chair to replace it bad times bro the
person who ran away with the golden seat
has raced back to his home and now the
chair is upstairs in his bedroom if
you're unsure if the thief likes Midas
look in the trash outside nope not a fan
oh and back to the crane at Ferris
Bueller's house well my prediction came
true the crane fell and now a bigger
crane has arrived to start out this mess
there's actually so much metal here now
that this could be a really good landing
spot campsites sprang up this week on
the island for a challenge and they
looked a lot like Pokemon campsites and
to add to that video game reference
multiple swords in stones could be found
everywhere very much like King Arthur's
fable or maybe The Legend of Zelda this
week it became apparent that the crashed
plane site is slowly being taken back by
nature and these little crustacean
fungus things cube ogres are taking the
island to I want some parts of the plane
have been stolen now and can be found in
pleasant park I have no idea the
importance of that on the other side of
the island the iron man the man of pipes
continue to walk on his journey and we
began to get where he could be going as
there's a mess of pipes very close to
him right now
down in the secret bare misfit base the
Teddy overlords are hoarding honey and
as we all learned at school honey is
AGGA gnomes favorite food and just
outside the Nome army we're keeping a
close eye on this location ready to
attack crazy
week eight week dead bull it finally
happened the Merc with a mouth arrived
in fortnight and immediately took over
the yacht's
he replaced everything throwing his
underwear around to prove he owns the
place and adding chimichangas and
changing Midas's statue too he even set
up a PC gaming streamer room so he could
cry about aim assists good times
another great touch was that the update
to the map which included Deadpool's own
art sketches in fact he paints an awful
lot remember when we wondered why the
box Factory was added this season
well the yacht was the answer after
Deadpool took over its musil's was
forced to leave finally setting up home
at the Box Factory he even cried to show
his plight but times bro week 9 let's
get over to lazy Lake the no sweat
insurance building has arrived we have
this in Chapter one and it could survive
a natural disaster I mean 8 a lava ball
to the face and still stuck around now
in chapter 2 the no sweat insurance
company have begun to place signage
around the island either protecting
their POS or marking them for
destruction
I guess we'll find out very soon a
little easter egg and potential hint
toward season 3 content could be found
at the Northwest
small pieces of posters could be located
suggesting a flood hmm I wonder
over at risky reels we could now watch
TV shows they were dreadful but on the
plus side there was bright pink Teddy's
to take around the island with you let's
go back to the two trucks racing towards
each other at breakneck speeds well in
week 9 they have finally collided
pallets and chairs thrown everywhere but
wait what is that at the foot of the
hill could this be the return of hot
watch let's check back next week over to
the known vs. Teddy war look what
happened this week the gnomes have taken
the bunker freeing their comrades and
capturing the Bears take that Nick furry
but the biggest change this week came at
the shark Pio eye the location was
converted into a prison the Eagle flags
remained so it's safe to say we all
voted for sky to be in the ghost squad
up here we can see a breakout attempt
and even a basketball court but further
north is where the interesting thing is
a singular prison away from everyone
else
whoever this one is for must be ultra
evil but who will it be
I know I said no theories in this video
but I'm really hoping that Midas will be
stuck in there next season
all season week 9 also saw a key change
down at the rig the skin in the cabinet
was replaced with this the only place
we'd seen this before
is in Midas's personal chambers hmm
another hint towards the event step
aboard the hype train my friend
[Music]
week ten the end of the seat no no it's
not the end of the season the season
will continue another five weeks but
that's okay that's okay week ten is here
let's do this
far away in the sky we could see a
meteorite kinda like the one in Chapter
one and then it all became clear a
concert would happen later in the week
thanks to posters found around the
island to compound this a stage began to
be built between the coral islands when
the time came we realized the stage
wasn't even needed because Travis Scott
is far taller in real life than I
expected we relived every story Beach
from Chapter one and I watched it five
times it gave me goosebumps every time
and then sorry it was seriously so damn
good though here's my 10-second review
without any of his music he went boom
and then danced a bit and had a walk
around then boots blush and then we did
some sliding around and then we flew a
bit and then it went bang and it all
finished yeah it was great he was really
good I should be a reviewer but I
probably should move on because
marshmallow might be watching week
eleven arrived and with it came
confirmation that hot watch is back when
I started this stupid word I was simply
looking for content for a video and now
it's in the game's code we've come a
long way baby thank you so much if
you've ever said hot watch in your life
to confirm the two trucks crashed into
each other they spilled their loads and
at the foot of the hill something is
being erected it's gonna take a long
long time for this to be finished but
come on we need the hot watch singer
right now Oh
tingles now let's get back to the golden
chair story which was taken from Midas's
agency to a house in salty Springs and
look now the weight of the chair has
smashed through the ceiling I guess it
was real gold and not painted man
there's a lot more updates this season
than I remember
back over at the NAM Teddy story and the
teddy bears escaped their incarceration
and ingame the war was moments away from
beginning luckily we were there to
disarm them all and hopefully a more
civilized resolution will be coming we
shall see and finally this week the
story of the pipe man Tony
thank ya like that name well the story
stopped the iron man now sits down
looking out to sea again
he's very chilled he's probably keeping
to social distancing rules so let's
leave in be week fourteen after three
weeks of absolutely nothing at all
happening in fortnight week fourteen
came to the rescue the most important
thing was hot watch i'm the cleanup
going on there it's only small steps
forwards but progress is here I'll keep
you posted
I mean it's got a window this is a
result for all of us speaking of results
let's check in on the feud and Wow
the terror is and the genomes have made
peace the pen really is mightier than
the sword I'm expecting this story to
continue next season they'll either fall
out again or maybe this union what bring
us all a new world order week 14 brought
is a weird cloud above the agency it's
almost a complete ring circling above
kind of like the start of a hurricane
which would link into the flood hinted
at last week with the no sweat building
our lobby screens were the next thing to
be impacted this week as Midas's room
changed in the background his doomsday
Weather Machine looks imminent and the
power supply supporting it looks
important too
I wonder if it has anything to do with
the woman in the picture
week 15 the very last week of chapter 2
season 2 what a journey this has been
the live event is almost here
the key things to note this week are
bubbles at the agency the nuclear silos
have stopped glowing purple and now
bubble away under the surface this
activity is replicated in Midas's room
with the doomsday device now a rave
activity this looks like it's going to
blow up so be careful where you stand
for the event around the island two
puddles began to be found and breaks in
the soil two are these linked to the
event at this point here's a random
suggestion a dynamic weather system in
season three maybe one game will have a
flood and another will be of drought and
all the water will be gone that's sounds
epic
sign me up epic some people have also
said that the river speeds have changed
but I couldn't prove that but if they
are good spot you people anyway have a
great time at the event I hope one of
you is able to build Hut watch before
the device is triggered I'll be keeping
an eye out for your builds I'll be back
with a cinematic view of the event this
Sunday and maybe a few secrets about the
device you didn't know a huge thanks to
those people on screen right now who
kindly used code atom arrow in the font
night shop
it honestly blows my mind that you stuck
with me for so long thank you I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]